less aliens and more alien that's an
important distinction for the creative
Assembly's upcoming survival horror game
alien isolation and it's one that fans
of the film series have been screaming
for for over 30 years the game is going
back to basics so that means you a
motion tracker and one single alien that
stalks you throughout the entire game
yeah with the starting point for this
was to create a game and then experience
which felt they hadn't been available
previously what is it like to encounter
and try and survive against that kind of
release gray and something was massive
and terrifying and something that felt
really intelligent was was hunting you
down set 15 years after the events of
alien you play as Ellen Ripley's
daughter Amanda who is on a mission to
find out what happened to her mother man
appears our own character and her own
personality but I guess she shares the
DNA with a mother and one of the traits
i think is that kind of what you know
you see an Ellen Ripley that she has
that kind of clarity of thought under
pressure whereas I think the rest of the
crew Romo died because they don't you
know I think we're anomaly is able to
strive to survive and it is challenging
which each entry measures do and I think
that's one of the qualities that we you
know
emphasizing amantha as you slowly creep
through claustrophobic corridors and
stick to the shadows in more open areas
the alien relentlessly pursues it has
its own system of air ducts that it
travels through and you can hear it
stomping and growling as you try to
avoid detection a complex AI drives its
unscripted search patterns so you can
never fully learn what it's going to do
or where it's going to be this keeps the
alien scary it also forces you to play
more reactively by scavenging for
components and crafting makeshift items
like flares and noisemakers a matter is
just as resourceful as her mother and
these items can be used to distract or
stun the alien giving her a chance to
slip past but these items aren't precise
and nothing works perfectly I think it
also feeds into the sort of the horror
the fact that well that is also saying
is that technology isn't the answer I
think it communicates that there's no
locker somewhere with a massive gun
that's going to be the answer to your
problem that is actually very mundane
and basic and it's clunky and it might
not work and it's a world away from kind
of the high side fight that thing we're
kind of kind of used to your motion
tracker glitches out if used in a small
space like a ventilation shaft and it
can't tell you whether the alien is
above or below you when you have it out
you can press a button to change your
focus from the tracker to the
environment itself so you can only
clearly see one or the other at a time
you can also lean in any direction which
is useful when keeping track of not just
the alien but the other humans that you
encounter within the story I think the
that's a small group of inhabitants have
splintered and have fallen apart and
everyone has forms kind of groups and so
yeah there is a lot of friction conflict
and yeah they're very desperate if I
moment a moment you're going to feel
that desperation yourself as the alien
makes short work of anything in its part
though there are weapons in the game
none can be used to actually kill the
alien so you'll need to outwit outrun
and outlast the unpredictable foe the
thing that's kind of new for us is the
fact that the alien is you know actually
scary and terrifying and and you know I
can play the game and leave and I play
it all day every day my heart will be
something because I can't predict what's
going to happen I think that's it that's
you know for the first time that's a
that's a major step forward in making
Union scary again